what does this mean for dak Prescott I
put the question out on Twitter today
what the Cowboys offer dak Prescott the
pack from a homes deal right now and if
so would Patrick mahomes deal be
accepted by dak Prescott I have to let
you know Macy's just walked into the
room I thought the door was closed so
she's in here sniffing around there's a
chance you'll see her she's under the
desk right now she thinks I may have
dropped some food I may have dropped
some potato chips last night so we're
just gonna keep this rolling this is a
new experience Maisie can you please
move here she's finally moved you may
see her in the background there she is I
can see her back there anyway
and she and I don't think she's been out
to use the bathroom today so there's a
chance she may bark at some point but
with that Prescott I don't believe he
would take this deal for one very
obvious reason he's not going to commit
for 12 years he'd much rather take I
believe the Ryan Tannehill contract for
years 118 million by the way Tannehill
over the next four years gonna make more
than Pat mahomes Tannehill got 62
million fully guaranteed at signing
mahomes got 63 million fully 214 at
signing I think between the two deals
dak would take Tannehill over my homes
we know dak only wants to do a four-year
deal so what does this mean for dak
Prescott look it Ottomans nothing
because Prescott's got 34-point note
thirty-one point four million in hand
for this year 37.6 made eight million in
hand for next year if they tagged him
again and then the opportunity to hit
the open marker to get a 44 percent
raise for 2022 I've been saying all
along the Cowboys have to offer him
something that will get him to trade in
what he could make this year next year
and come 2022 whether they tagged him
again at a 44 percent raise or they let
it become a free agent
Patrick mahomes deal means nothing to
dak Prescott
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports